I barely slept last night
because I was so nervous about this hourglass
Barney's meet and greet that I was doing,
but you guys showed up, and this made my week.
I started glam pretty early.
I always have to use my hourglass concealer.
The ones that have been around for a while know how much I love it.
All the rest of my touch UPS,
and then it was time to finish putting on my outfit.
I was so excited to get this on that I ripped the zipper,
so my tailor had to come over and literally sew me into my dress,
put the skirt over, got it all snug,
then I realized how late we were,
so we grabbed the kids and started getting into the cars.
Getting two toddlers and a baby into a car as a task,
but we managed. And then headed over to the pop up.
I had some time to walk around the store,
look at all the hourglass makeup,
look at all the amazing designers that were showing in the space.
I also tried all the snacks and drinks that Fred's made
before heading out to meet all of you.
I can't believe how many of you guys came.
I love chatting with you guys,
answering questions, just hanging out and getting to know all of you.
I can't believe how far some of you guys traveled,
and I couldn't be more grateful.
This was such a magical experience
that I Couldn't stop crying on the way back to the hotel.